well what does it mean when y is a
function of X well what it means is that
when you put your input in your x value
you're only getting out one Y value okay
so you can see here X is mapping to Y
now in this case here you can see when
we're putting in a given x value we're
getting more than one output more than
one y value out so what that tells us is
that it's not a function now you might
have learned this when you learned about
the vertical line test say for example I
have a graph that looks like this okay
you can see here if I go over to when X
is two and I go up to the graph I have a
Y value here as well as here so for that
given input of x equals two I'm actually
getting two different Y values and it's
failing that vertical line test so Y is
not a function of X but you can think of
it either you know like this mapping
that I've drawn here or you can graph it
or you know you can plug in some points
and kind of test it out using the
equation itself so another option as
well as to solve for y if possible you
know try to get that Y value by itself
and you'll be able to identify whether
there's a you know more than one output
for a given input so let's go into some
examples and you'll see how what I mean
by this so say for number one y equals
3x plus one well we know what y equals
3x plus one looks like right it's a
y-intercept of 1 and it has a slope of 3
so it's looking something like that
approximately right so you can see it's
passing that vertical line test meaning
for every x value there's only one Y
value and that a corresponds to on the
graph another option is you can see like
you know if I put in values for X I can
see that I'm only gonna get one output
for y okay so we know that this is a
function so we're gonna say yes for this
one
okay let's look at the next one number
two y squared equals 64 X now in this
case you can see this is y squared we
want to solve just for y so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take the
square root of both sides remember when
you take the square root of both sides
of an equation you actually get two
answers right plus or minus so this is
plus or minus square root of 64 we know
is 8 and we're left with the square root
of x we can't really simplify that now
let's analyze this a little bit if I put
in though say for example x equals 1
right square root of 1 is 1 times 8 is 8
but you're
we're getting pause of eight and also
negative eight right so for that one
input x equals one we're getting an
output of positive eight and negative
eight so that tells us that Y is not a
function of X the other thing we can do
is we can graph this and we'll see that
it fails that vertical line test this is
actually a parabola that's on its side
like like so and so it's failing that
vertical line test okay let's look at
number three this one we've got three x
squared minus y equals two so again what
we can do here is we can you know test
out some points but what I like to do is
I like to try to solve for y I like to
try to get that lie by itself so here
we're going to multiply everything by
negative one just to solve for positive
one Y that's going to be three x squared
minus two everything multiplied by
negative one right okay that's our final
equation but if we know what this graph
looks like we can see it's a parabola
see that quadratic and the minus two is
just shifting it down to where as the 3
is like stretching it by by three so
it's like making a little bit narrower
so it's going up faster it's a vertical
stretch but when we do that vertical
line test you can see that as we go
across the graph is it crossing at more
than one point no so that means for
every x value there's only one Y value
so that means that Y is a function of X
and so this one is a function so we're
gonna write yes for this one